bitcoin is still holding strong we've
got a whole bunch of data we're going to
run through on bitcoin because bitcoin
is slowly becoming the global store of
value people from around the world
millions of people are all deciding to
protect their purchasing power by
storing it in bitcoin we can see that
bitcoin now has hit 62 000
it is way
better performing than s p 500 gold
silver euro yen remnant b and oil
bitcoin continues to stay strong in the
60 000 mark it was about thirty thousand
dollars over the summer if we then go
ahead and we look at the bitcoin
statistics of the actual network itself
we're sitting about one point one seven
trillion dollar market cap we have
eighty nine point seven percent of the
supply already in circulation and of
course the bitcoin settlement volume
18.8 billion dollars settled on chain
not on exchanges only on chain
settlement volume of 18.8 billion if you
look at that 1.17 trillion dollar market
cap that means about 1.5
of all bitcoin in circulation has traded
hands and settled on chain in the last
24 hours on top of that we've got over 1
million active addresses in the last 24
hours and miners were paid
56.8 million dollars in the last 24
hours to secure the strongest computing
network in the world that's how this
game is played these financial
incentives drive the world and what we
are watching is that the bitcoin network
the financial incentives are taking over
if we then go and we look at the return
on invested assets or the return on
investment over the last couple of years
we can see that bitcoin continues to
remain dominant it is at 366 percent
over the last one year and it is about a
thousand percent over the last four
years if we look at gold gold is the
only asset that on this entire chart
between bitcoin gold and s p 500 it is
down six percent on a nominal basis
investors around the world dropped gold
and picked up bitcoin gold is down
double digits on a real return basis
with over five percent inflation pretty
freaking crazy if we then look we had
willy woo come out with an amazing
statistic this one blew my mind he said
excluding the lost coins the average
bitcoin owner has approximately 4 000
of exposure today
so if you look at all of the different
holders that are actually on the bitcoin
network and holding the bitcoin asset
and you take away the circulating supply
for those coins that we know are lost
that's about four thousand dollars on
average per investor so this is an asset
class that is going to continue to
appreciate in dollar terms as the
individual price of bitcoin goes up and
more and more holders are here so to see
that number really blew my mind the
second one is if we look over the last
week at the bitcoin miners we just
talked about just over 50 million
dollars in the last 24 hours but dylan
leclair showed that genera that the
bitcoin miners have generated 428
million dollars about 6 800 bitcoin in
revenue over the last seven days in
exchange for securing the world's most
dominant decentralized monetary network
and so 428 million dollars paid two
miners in a decentralized way all these
miners around the world no one told them
what to do simply the financial
incentive got them to go out acquire
hardware plug into energy and run
businesses so that they can run a
decentralized network and continue to
secure and validate transactions for
what has become the strongest computer
network in the world 428 million dollars
a week absolutely incredible to watch if
we then go ahead and we look also dylan
pointed out the bitcoin balances on
exchanges is at its lowest level since
2018. and so when you think about why is
it important to see that the bitcoin on
the exchanges is that a low number well
simple if there's bitcoin that's sitting
on the exchange it's easier for people
to sell it on the exchange there's the
potential for more cell pressure but if
people go onto the exchange they buy
bitcoin and then they go ahead and
withdraw it from the exchange that means
it is less likely that they're going to
go ahead and they're going to actually
sell that bitcoin on the exchange so to
see low levels of bitcoin balances on
exchanges is a very very bullish thing
as he points out there's increasing
demand there's a fixed supply there's
low bitcoin uh balances on the exchanges
likely to be a bullish event moving
forward and then last but not least the
lightning network continues to be on an
absolute tear the lightning network
capacity is now hitting an all-time high
yesterday of
3138 bitcoin on the lightning network
and so when we start to see going all
the way back to the end of september
there has just been a tear it continues
to add more and more nodes more and more
users and more and more capacity the
lightning network is one of the layer
two solutions in the world that is
getting real world product market fit
there was no coin that was used to
incentivize people or anything this is
an organic network that has been
bootstrapped by people from around the
world looking to use bitcoin a
decentralized digital currency in a
cheaper faster more instantaneous way
the lightning network continues to be on
that tear showing that there is real
world adoption real world use cases and
everyone from countries like el salvador
to large social media companies like
twitter all plugging into the network
and starting to integrate and transact
with everyone else on that network
pretty cool to see what do we think
right now in terms of bitcoin and some
of these statistics the show 428 million
dollars paid to minors and then such
incredible growth to lightning network
yeah it's crazy and i think just from
like when you look at price appreciation
the things are obvious there's low
demand and low balances on exchanges
currently but just from fundamental
supply and demand uh there there's a
fixed supply it's constrained we know
exactly how much it is it's programmatic
etc the lowest demand is or the lowest
amount of supplies currently in
circulation
and 85 is being held by strong or
long-term holders uh and there's
increasing demand coming in the market
from institutional investors
corporations are putting on their
balance sheet we're seeing new deal
after new deal come out where pension
funds are buying and countries are
buying and it's now legal tender et
cetera and you just start thinking about
all this in totality and you start to
quickly realize that there's really no
other way for the price to go if the
supply side or if the supply side stays
the same and demand keeps increasing so
i think these are just reminders right
and the on-chain metrics are wonderful
and they're an awesome addition to this
market because you can really see what
is happening in real time with the
market and it's one of the only things
in the world that offer that but i think
ultimately you just have to step back
and look in totality demand is
increasing supply is fixed that's a good
thing